most countries that have nuclear weapons
went to a great deal of effort to
acquire them
and so the odds of them ever willingly
giving them up are pretty slim with some
notable exceptions
so when you're a brand new country like
ukraine in 1991 and you've just been
handed the third largest nuclear arsenal
in the world and thereby a boatload of
clout why would you give it up
why did ukraine disarm its nuclear
weapons so to begin when the ussr came
down with a mild case of collapse things
like the armed forces administration and
its industry were mostly divided up by
whatever happened to be within the
nation's new borders
and for ukraine as well as belarus and
kazakhstan this meant that they got to
keep the nuclear weapons that the
previous soviet government had left on
their soil
now when the ussr collapsed there was a
lot of discussion amongst the nuclear
powers about how these new nuclear
states would be treated
and importantly how to get them to
disarm belarus and kazakhstan quickly
made it clear that they didn't want to
keep these nuclear weapons and so they
asked for help in getting rid of them
yet when it came to the subject of
nuclear disarmament ukraine's new
government wasn't saying much
and it became clear that its leaders
were clearly thinking of keeping them
so why didn't they well the first reason
was the lack of political willpower
ukraine's economy was firmly in the
toilet in 1991
and so maintaining a nuclear weapons
program when people are struggling to
find work isn't
exactly a good look there was a lot of
pressure from opposition parties the
general public and importantly the
international community
and this plays into the second reason
why the united states
the western powers had together created
a series of large financial aid packages
for the former soviet states
and whilst many nations had no
conditions on their aid the american
assistance had one caveat
no more nuclear weapons america wanted
this because it had just signed a series
of nuclear disarmament treaties with the
ussr and ukraine keeping them would have
slowed any potential
progress because nobody knew if it
actually counted towards soviet
disarmament or not
the third reason was that whilst the
ukrainian government could have
maintained the bombs creating a brand
new nuclear weapons program from scratch
would have been very difficult they'd
have gotten no outside help and leaving
a bunch of nukes on the shelf for 30
years without knowing how to handle them
isn't exactly safe
to further make things more difficult
ukraine didn't actually have the ability
to use the weapons
since things like armament codes and the
know-how for launching icbms was the
exclusive remit of the moscow-based
armed forces
and they weren't going to share these
could have been reverse engineered
eventually but again
it was a lot of time a lot of money and
a lot of political capital just to upset
everyone
so why even consider keeping them at all
well it was because owning such weapons
could essentially
guarantee that you'd never be invaded
since the cost for the invader would be
far too high
and for those who lived in ukraine there
were fierce memories of the last time
such an invasion happened
the world's powers understood this
concern and so they all came to an
agreement
the budapest memorandum this saw the usa
russia and the uk all agree to mutually
respect the territorial integrity of
these three states in return for their
nuclear disarmament
this wasn't a defensive treaty just a
promise to agree that this was ukraine
and that the powers involved wouldn't
use military or economic actions to
destabilize it
the ukrainian government accepted this
and that sweet aid money quite happily
because its primary concern was that the
united states would use economic
sanctions against it which this treaty
protected against
with the backing of russia whom the
ukrainian government saw as a steadfast
friend
since their only major post-soviet
disagreement by this point was about
basing rights in crimea
which fortunately would be sorted out
pretty quickly and would never ever come
up again
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly moneymaker marvin
cassal mo aaron the white
james castaneda marcus arsenal jordan
longley gustav swann rasheed ali
jerry lambda maggie patzkowski
coppertone winston k wood spencer
lightfoot robert wetzel spinning three
plates caught show wolf matthew shipley
anthony beckett and charles the first